we're live gentlemen hello good morning
good afternoon good evening wherever the
hell you are in the world and welcome to
Sidra you SciFi TV and Movie Channel I'm
getting I'm this I'm that the movie
channel is is getting more cow
like Movie Channel I like it yeah it's
we're two years in now a little over two
years in now and it's it's
getting longer but anyway hello
everybody how are we all doing hey how
howy good I'm doing well been doing
doing well wearing I'm just wearing this
oh I like it you're out doing me
there we're just doing a fun silly
little video for um for our friends over
at the companion and uh guess guess
guess why I was wearing this guys get in
the comments why why would I be wearing
that anyway you want it to be me I'm
just it's just because I love yes I love
Matthew so much that I just want to be
more like him so um that's why that's
also why I'm losing my hair so it's got
nothing to do with genetics it's just to
be more like Matthew i w to be i w to be
like
Matthew anyway hello everybody I am just
we'll just go through the thing Bob's
in hanging with the
family dve Stewart I Dave be hello all
Jordan you're with us uh Harris is with
us
obviously Mr red
Laura Laura Laura Sarah hello
everybody good morning s oh got that
that thing's tickled my nose actually
right we're only hanging out today we
don't really have a topic but we did a
question yesterday about um and guys get
into the comments throw us questions if
you want to we we'll talk about whatever
today um but we were asked a question
yesterday about um streaming versus sort
of like the network
why does streaming do these 10 episode
seasons and they they still do them now
um why do they do that and I don't think
this is going to be a massively long
conversation but it is an interesting
conversation because we're gonna be
getting Stargate soon and the chances
are it's going to be a 10 episode run if
we do if we get serious or when we get
serious so why
I've I've got two theories on this well
two two two points the first point on
this is
obviously they've got they got less
budget than everyone
else and at least initially because the
the question was posed before they were
like big when Netflix first started sort
of thing yeah they would they would have
only really been able to afford 10
episodes but I think now it's slightly
different it's not that they can't
afford it I think it's just now they've
realized they can they can just do the
story in 10 episodes rather than drag
out a 22 season story and have like
little Filler episodes here and there
and then like clip shows and stuff like
Stargates historically had they don't
need to do that they they can just
basically just do the entire story and
if that only takes 10 it only takes 10
yeah things like stranger things for
example
um the story obviously isn't finished
after season one it carries on so it's
not like they're going to get the entire
story done in those six to 10 episodes
or whatever we
get but we don't get any fellow don't
get any crap that makes sense not that
fellow episodes are crap because some of
them are really good but they're not the
story and I think that's a large part of
it but I think initially it would have
been the money side but now it's just
like just like a standard thing anyway
so it's not it's it's kind of just like
why wouldn't they do 10 why why why
stretch out 22 when no one else
is what you think
conis well I mean I I can't really think
of too many shows actually were 10
episodes Game of Thrones was always
about 10 but most shows I feel like
Netflix wise were always 13 and a lot of
those other early streaming services
were 13 or like 16 episodes like I guess
streaming went to not streaming uh cable
went two 16 episodes Walking Dead was
always
16 um stuff like that and
then as as streaming went on we went to
even less than 10 like Marvel is usually
six or eight Star Wars has always been
about eight uh they're animated kind of
gone to 16 from 22 or like 13 14 from 22
it's just I I'm kind of with Matt where
I think it's just less filler or or less
fluff they they don't necessarily have
uh that quota to fill so they have just
more time to streamline I guess and or
less time to streamline because they're
afforded that something like that I
think it's a good thing that we actually
get less I agree I think it's a good
thing we actually get less because
thinking about it shows that still do
the 22 episode run the only one I can
think of um of recent times is The Flash
there was a lot of episodes in there
that just they they could have cut them
out completely and it could have only
been 13 episodes they think they used to
do 22 Episodes a season and half of them
you could just cut out and just not have
yeah and it would still make sense and
it would be even better because I think
it was season six or season seven the
last one um literally the first half of
that season was crap it was a villain
that went nowhere they defeated him
within like three or four episodes just
get rid of that just get rid of that and
just do the do the actual thing yeah uh
Jordy we don't know yet because it's
completely being Rewritten so we have no
idea the new show runers come on and
it's being completely redone completely
scra start again so it could be anything
I honestly think look at the end of the
day networks have a season to fill so
they have 22 weeks they've got to fill
and they they filled it so um they
basically have two major Seasons a year
basically and they they've got to fill
them and they have the Christmas in
between and so so that's why they still
do 22 Episodes and I think you're right
A lot of them are Filler episodes I do
think though that there's been a move
towards doing story arc Seasons so you
do a series now that has one story it's
like a 10-hour movie or eight hour movie
or 13 or whatever um it's not monster of
the week stuff it's not you know before
they would do a series and it was um it
was more about the series if that makes
sense the characters and the story would
be a different story each week you know
Law and Order blah blah blah it's a
different story ER whatever you might
have an overarching story with
characters in between but generally
speaking there's a different story each
week that's not the fashion
nowadays um I mean we still get those
shows on
networks but I think you're right I
think because the fashion is to do
these um one
story it just it just you you don't need
22 Episodes and they can do as many
episodes as they bloody like he's with
us there he is fashionably late as
always Danny
Gandalf we'll catch you up in a sec as
soon as I finish my and I can't hear
anybody between six and 13 episodes yeah
um the other point is can't hear us
so to talk about him
yeah his stupid beard we can give him
some sign
language he probably thinks we're all
like just gaslighting
him
yeah um but the other thing is with
sci-fi and stuff pretending we don't
hear
him um we can hear you
stormy we can hear him yeah he can't
hear
us but anyway let's keep going because
you know it's a show how how
entertaining is it us all just sitting
watching looking at stormy
going um hear anything sorry I'll be
back you can hear
me the storinator yeah but with a lot of
sci-fi man these shows cost a freaking
Fortune that's a good
point um I mean the expanse was
considered a reasonably cheap show to
produce and they still spent four four5
million an episode that's that's 4045
million $50 million for season that's a
lot of money in anybody's book um you
know um Apple just did the foundation
and they can again that's considered to
be done at a bargain price of $45
million it's crapload of money
um get know I don't think we will ever
see a 22 episode Sci-Fi show again
because it's it's not practical from a
finance point of view it's just not used
to do Star Trek and there was nothing
like the special effects that we expect
now or the or the level it was far more
um about the characters and and things
and then a lot of the special effects
were reused over and over and over again
um which again we wouldn't allow anymore
um am I
buffering no you're good okay it's just
iio toy buffering buffering Bing
buffering it might be because I'm using
the um I can turn the um green screen
it's um when it's got the the two dots
next to it it's a icon that but it
doesn't appear in streamyard ah so um
but you know that is I think that is an
important point that you know it's just
it's there's a financial reason why we
can't can you hear us hey I can hear you
finally thank you thank you there we go
this time change is just really screwed
with my head I am so so so sorry I'm
late
yeah your
hear go back soon so we can get back in
line do I do your clocks go back at some
point so we get back in line well I
think they already flipped back but I
was thinking it was 10 and not nine my
local
time okay so at least at least so stormy
we were just talking about why the
streaming services do 10 episodes for a
season and why don't they why didn't
they follow the model of doing um you
know 22 Episodes like the um you know
like the networks and I was just saying
look particularly with sci-fi I think
the big chunk of it is cost um but but
what do you think is there is there a
reason why streamer Services decided to
do
that uh well
uh well I always thought that um well
you know Ronald Moore when he's doing
Battle Star
Galactica you know he said you know when
I think the the last season that had to
truncate down there the number of
episodes they shot for the last season
he was saying it was easier to produce
lesser episodes because stories could be
more impactful because if you have like
22 27 episodes you start having a lot of
Filler episodes you know and one thing
now not a lot of streaming services do
this or it turns out that they kind of
fail at this but with 10 episodes you
get right to the guts of the story you
know it's not it doesn't become like you
know a soap opera that it's a daily
incremental tiny change to the story at
least that's what I
think I wonder how many actors would
sign on I mean obviously they still do
on the big network shows but doing a big
Network show is a
slog it it what's it's nine or 10 months
of the year doing 14 hours a day um
barely getting a day off you know I
remember seeing Nathan fillian talking
about doing castle and he says by the
end of it you can tell I'm not happy I I
he says I got really bloated I I was
tired um because the show centered
around him so he had to be in every day
in almost every scene um even if he
wasn't talking he's in the background he
says it was freaking exhausting and now
he does um the rookie there's it's a
much bigger cast and it's a much easier
sort of thing um but yeah I I wonder how
many actors are looking at doing a like
a network show if they've got the choice
obviously you know working actors and
going [__] me I don't want to do that
for the next 10 years in my life if the
show's successful I could be doing this
for six or seven years um it's painful
yeah and I don't think there's the um
Quality there to be honest either but
that's mine J there any hey Tom how you
doing and and car's in the house um do
you think there's any other reasons and
which do we prefer or does it depend on
the type of genre does it work better
for some some types of genre shows and
others sort of thing I think it works in
any and every genre it's just it's
expensive and you can't tell the story
that you want to tell and like the
conciseness that you want to I guess uh
but animated might be a good way to like
Herald that into the future maybe I
don't know I feel like there's still a
space for monster of the week or
character of the week or villain of the
week whatever it kind of is but it's it
it does doesn't give you the story that
you really want necessarily it does
allow you to play with some characters
but that's about it um not necessarily
it
but it's not the way of the future
that's for
sure yeah well I mean future armor does
that kind of to an extent does it I mean
it's just like Adventure of the week
kind of thing I know sometimes they they
went in and had like an overarching
theme a few seasons here and there
but with animation like you say you can
literally just have of the week
adventure of the week kind of things I
don't know why doesn't it work for Live
Action as well nowadays what it used to
I think that's quite interesting because
it doesn't translate anymore like I
expect taste have changed I
guess um I think T I think expectations
have changed okay 100% potentially
exactly with sci-fi things I think this
is a really interesting point and I'd
love to know what you guys think I
believe the next installment in the
Stargate franchise will have a proper
sci-fi budget first of all what do you
think a proper sci-fi budget is we'll
talk about then otherwise Amazon MGM
will literally risk throwing millions of
dollars out the window what is a proper
sci-fi budget what do they need to spend
that dude that that's the dude writing
the script on Twitter using my
[Music]
DMs sorry I just saw his face I like I
know
you I'm swear that's him
[Music]
well a proper sci-fi budget I'm saying
would be 40 to 50 million because just
expanse and and Foundation are both like
Pinnacle sci-fi shows of what we
consider is like a a Sci-Fi community
and those are yeah perfectly budgeted in
a
way Star Trek spends nine eight n
millionar an
episode they
do and they're still fluff I think that
40 50 million is kind of perfect because
it forces the people making it the whole
creative team to really focus on what
they're spending the money on compared
to that like eight nine 10 million
dollars where I mean I don't watch Star
Trek sorry y'all but like I I know it's
not like the super most popular thing in
the world you said uh Bard got in the
top 10 of neelen but maybe they could do
better if they were forced to hone in on
their story more instead of going to do
like musical episodes and stuff that I
know some people are the biggest fans of
and stuff I was getting ready to say
somebody mentioned uh filler in the chat
and it's like that's the first thing
that popped to my to my head was strange
new worlds in their
musical yeah yeah the Marvel's had a
little musical I personally than you
Sarah I personally thought the K-pop
Kling gons was a marvelous moment in
sci-fi and um you know I actually think
they should do a whole episode of it I
think it' be
great i' no I want to stick my fingers
in my AR
balls um I would rather put my dick in a
clamp than watch that episode
again all right I would tell us how you
really feel it was terrible it was I I
would rather use a cheese grater on my
testicles watch that that episode again
it was awful um 5 to8 million so what
the votes we're getting at the moment
more
like um
John Campbell wants to put his wants to
cheese grate his testicles as well well
he doesn't want to wants to he would
rather do that then I'm not here to Kink
shame I'm not here to K shame at all
but and then rub salt into it
um it was that bad
um I think it very much depends with
starget where it ends up if it goes to
Amazon
Prime um it's not going to in America
anyway internationally it'll almost
certainly end up on Prime but in America
if it goes on Prime I think they'll get
eight seven or 8 million an
episode um I know um when they were
looking at doing a series before
Jennifer Suki dropped the film bomb that
they were asking for 10 but I was told
that was a negotiation tactic you know
go High Hope for about seven um because
Amazon was saying three or four I think
about four or five six million dollars
an episode
is is doable yeah five six would be yeah
perfect I mean look at Foundation four
five million an episode and it's
visually stunning and story driven it's
just great yeah I mean even if you don't
like the show you cannot argue that it
doesn't look good because it
does you know there's there's a lot of
sets there there's a lot going on so I
mean you can't argue that they every
penny of that you know of that budget
was on the
screen what what what do you guys think
then I
mean if they don't spend that sort of
money is it a
problem what do you mean if they don't
spend five or six million or if they
don't spend 10 if they if they come back
and we find out their budget is $3
million because it's going on MGM plus
and three million for MGM plus C Series
is about what they spend they've got a
new Sci-Fi show come on I forget what
it's called I apologize it is I think it
Premier in the next couple of weeks it
does look good actually like life can't
remember it's called um but the budget
for that has been 30 to4 million for 10
episodes if they do the same with
Stargate and I will tell you now in
America this is almost certainly going
to go in MGM
plus when they do a series
I mean a lot of the CGI that they're
going to be
using if they follow what the old
Stargate used to do is really going to
be Weaponry which isn't really going to
be that much you've got the Stargate
opening which they can create once and
just have like varying different
shots I mean there'll probably be some
spaceships but if you've got a 3D model
that's not going to be hard to to
[Music]
animate
yeah it's just going to be like location
and stuff I mean if it means for the
first season or so which is still stuck
in the woods again so be it because if
it gets popular they'll get more budget
and then we can have like quaries
perhaps yeah but will it get more Budget
on MGM
plus I don't know that's what I mean if
it if it becomes if if it gets the
viewing figures they want surely they're
going to look at that and go right cool
season two you're going to get a little
bit more money because we want to like
milk this cash cow they're gonna have to
they're a
business well think about I think
sometimes smaller budgets can cause
creativity I mean what do you think
stormmy I mean I'm thinking about things
like Babylon 5 tiny budget compared to
Star Trek at the time D space9 and I
would argue I've actually just done a
video recorded it this afternoon talking
about how everyone copied babyon 5 ever
since I think it was people talk about
Deep Space 9 or no well people talk
about Battle Star Galactica being genre
in I think Babylon 5 was John defining
but but what do you think can a smaller
budget be more you know lead to more
creativity well uh certainly uh he rung
out the budget I mean they were doing 20
some episode seasons was that correct
for Babylon 5 and if I recall correctly
they were
using they were doing their special
effects on I forget what the name it was
a an amga computer yeah I mean basically
household computer apparently yeah and
so you
really you really can't get cheaper than
those things you know and um he
absolutely
um he
he he kind his film making style kind of
reminded me of
um oh God I'm blinking on everything
today um Hitchcock Hitchcock had a lot
of when he was running big he had access
to all the toys that the uh studio and
the camera Department could throw at him
but he used each of them judiciously and
cheaply um and the same thing can be
said for Babylon five is you know he
went let's just go get a bunch of Amigas
and loaded up with a 3D animation
software and just let them render
forever and um he did that for 20 20
some episodes per season
and it kept going and the acting was
good and the writing of course was just
awesome um so it can be done you know
now if if you go to you know watch
Babylon 5 today it looks a bit dated but
how many years ago was that
1993 30 94
93 early 80s early 80s when
um when syndication was becoming big and
syndication was a really good outlet for
sci-fi uh but yeah I
mean there's a lot of other shows that
start like somebody else mentioned in
the chat you know um Orphan Black did a
lot with no
budget
um and but I think you see you can it's
possible to definitely do a Sci-Fi show
on the sheet still today it should be
cheaper I mean you know because now the
the power of those Amigas can be done on
your it's on it's your phone or Pro the
phone's more powerful and so
the I'm not sometimes I don't understand
how these production budgets get so big
unless it's just the marketing side of
it I see that a lot
um but you know when you do something
like peard a lot of the costs are above
the line you know they're all going into
director's Pockets the the actors which
I'm not complaining about yeah
Patrick So when you say that you when
people say that it is uh oh it's it's
it's the special
effects man I I would say the cost of
you know um Patrick Stewart's trailer
costs more than the effects on peard
because I mean because his salary was so
high compared to what the effects are I
think yeah well I think they would have
spent more on the effects than his
trailer but I know you I know what
you're saying it does inflate the cost
when if the actor's
earning a million pound an episode you
know and his contract I think was about
15 million um which would be you know
that's 10% of the budget goes on
Patrick's sh
basically what what do you think Matt do
you
think right remember like the old Sci-Fi
TV shows um on the Sci-Fi Network and
the most of them were rubbish um or but
then we would get something like
Andromeda or um you know some of these
shows that were just phenomenal sci-fi
is it is there is there a point to say
sometimes and I think Star Trek is
guilty of this sometimes you can spend
too much money Lord of the Rings you can
spend too much money and it's like it's
it becomes CGI for me someone in the
comments said this
earlier it's better to have like three
million episodes $3 million or whatever
per episode and have a really great
story than to spend 10 million on like
special effects and it just be complete
crap yeah it's always been about the
story for Stargate for me the special
effects are great like don't get me
wrong I love I love this I love seeing
the spaceships and I like seeing people
get blown up and and all that kind of
stuff but it was always the story that
that kept me coming back and the
character development if it didn't have
spaceships I would still love it because
for the first six seasons we didn't have
any spaceships yeah other than like
attack vessels and like the OD Asgard
[__] but
yeah Harris do you actually think it
could be a good thing because if it
means a low budget it means they might
have to strip this show back and we keep
talking about how there's the risk of we
want Stargate not Star Trek so I mean
smaller budget they've got to strip it
back right I totally think it's a good
thing I just think $3 million is too low
to bring something back that is the
third largest sci-fi kind of Ip out
there even if it's the dormant sleeping
giant one uh I think four to six million
is kind of that sweet spot and and five
or six would be that like perfect kind
of sweet spot three million would be
okay I think that would force them to do
some stuff and I think but but five or
six kind of forces them to uh confine
their story and really like have a plan
of what they want to do with it more so
than like okay spend $10 million doll
and like give it some fluff have some
fun with it uh I like the conis of it
but three million just seems too low
just a little too low I would love it if
Amazon actually went to the story makers
and went What story do you want to do
what do you think it's going to cost and
actually the budget was more related to
the story they wanted to do rather than
them saying you've got $4 million an
episode what's the best you can do it'd
be nice that be
nice I love spin's question here guys so
let's let's move on we got some great
questions coming through at the moment
uh would you rather have Stargate wait
an extra year for a TV show that will at
least run five seasons hopefully seven
or would you rather have a movie and a
TV show start right away but there's a
5050 chance that the show only last two
seasons I'm I I'm G to switch say do we
want something do we want it now
regardless or would we actually prefer
they took their time even if that means
we wait
this I would argue that as well we'
waited long enough
now yeah well it's not like they haven't
technically taken their time already you
know so I think they should go ahead and
jump in on something if the obviously
it'd be nice to have a series that's
going to run the link of something that
we all would want to watch for a long
time years and years and years but I
mean you mentioned another the other day
like hey maybe they're GNA do a Trilogy
of movies and stuff I would not mind a
movie two seasons of something that kind
of counts as a minseries another movie
and if if that movie led into the
miniseries the miniseries led into the
movie so on so forth and then that ended
maybe after the trilogy with that long
running series that would be amazing uh
because that that just allow different
stories to be told in kind of half
different mediums not necessarily
different mediums but in different ways
and and you get to spend more time with
those characters than just those three
movies and it could still be like one
larger overarching story that leads into
a a long series and that could tie up
sg1 SGA SGU so on so
forth yeah I'd agree with that off my
Soap
Box well one thing that um I've been
thinking about this last week and one of
the biggest reasons why at least for me
I'm attracted to Stargate is a great
writing but the thing I like the most
about Stargate is the heroes are
scientists you know and you see like
most disaster movies it starts out with
somebody ignoring the scientist you know
and then oh yeah well let's go get the
scientist to figure out how do we defeat
Godzilla
uh but one thing that they never did
back away from and they had it not just
one but two you know with uh Colonel
Carter and Andrew Jackson is they had
and okay Rodney McCay love that
character I mean they always had
scientists as the backbone of the the
the characters and I love that love
that even the military guys were pretty
smart Jack and uh Shephard were
you know as as much as a jack O'Neal
like to play Dum you know he's an
astronomer I mean he's got a telescope
nice telescope set up on his house and
that's where the action is and he's you
know looking at the
stars would it be a problem for you guys
if they announced this and they said it
is going to be on MGM
plus because I think they're actually
trying to push MGM plus as its own thing
like Paramount like thing Amazon Prime
doesn't want to be like a subscription
channel in its own right it wants to be
a subscription
Hub so they're going to be pushing these
they're going to be pushing free they're
going to be pushing MGM plus and these
sort of things so this this show is
going to end up on one of
those what do you I mean I tell you I
mean we're talking about the Babylon 5
reboot at the moment and I've heard
several times now the same rumor that
it's going to be going on freey that
Amazon are trying to get it for freey
when they do the babyon 5
reboot and I think it's perfect to be
honest it just feels like a freev show
to me I don't I don't know why but
um do you think where it ends up is a
big
problem it it for me it won't I mean um
but others it might I mean they really
have to you know they're GNA spend a
bunch of money on it do we want to use
it as the backbone of a brand new
streaming service like we don't have
enough already I don't know there only
about 25 calm down I tell you what
though MGM plus is like six quid there's
nothing on it and it's like six quid a
month and I'm like what six quid is
nothing it's a cup of coffee but I mean
it's like when you start adding them all
on to all the other bloody things we've
got it starts to become quite expensive
yeah I
like I just say that the the thing that
when you keep having these U streaming
services pop up with one big ENT Pole
Series people will go oh yeah let me go
join 30 days they cancel their
subscription and they're done they go on
to something else because we don't have
you know really you know large volumes
of um content on single providers now
that was probably a bad thing to have
but you know because it's kills
competition in kind of a way but um man
we got there's got to be some
consolidation because I'm getting way
too many yeah yeah yeah apps um on my
system to just to continually watch I me
I still come keep coming back to the the
The Usual Suspects you know Disney plus
and Hulu and Amazon Etc and Netflix
those are the kind of the four I bounce
between and unless there's
something like I want to go you know get
my daily dose of uh classic Doctor Who
then I'll go to Pluto TV which is free
which don't cost anything not like I
honestly think Amazon are missing a
trick they need to have Amazon Plus
because everything else has got a plus
in it Amazon Plus where is a bundle you
know what I mean it's Amazon but it's
MGM it's how are they not doing that
already for like even if it was like 20
quid but
you
yeah Matt what do you think about this
me I
already well for me I already pay for
Amazon Prime I don't pay for it for the
for the streaming because realistically
the only thing I watch on there at the
moment is the boys when that comes out
every every year or so movie on I pay
for
it yeah I watch some of the movies every
now and then but I re I mainly pay for
it for the free shipping and for like
twitch
stuff I wouldn't mind paying a little
bit extra like a couple of quid more to
have their entire and like foro like the
twitch stuff perhaps like you can have
this or that kind of thing so they're
still making the money elsewhere to have
MGM plus and whatever else they've got
on there because they're trying to like
a a hub thing aren't they yeah they're
trying to
be if they went if they put a price for
and it was like so what do I pay now
$7.99 something like that if if it was
like for for an extra two quid you can
pick one of these Services Happy Days
MGM plus yeah that's the only one well
because they have the music thing as
well they should have like Amazon Ultra
where it's you get Prime you get you
could get like so many free movies
a month or something like to rent or
something say it's like $30 30 quid or
something but then MGM plus is included
Lions Gate or one of these other you
know smaller channels that nobody really
pays for stars or whatever throw in
Disney if they could do a deal with
Disney throw in Disney or something and
Netflix would get into that Netflix be
jump all over that it's the sort of
thing they love um you know and then
yeah have have Amazon Ultra and if even
if it was 30 quid but you were getting
your
music these Services all in one place
and then like like I said they throw in
a couple of couple of rentals a month or
something as part of the package like
two rentals a month or something people
would I'd pay for that all day but
anyway co clud uh Mike asked a question
if Stargate returns to TV show would you
like to return the classic villains of
the go World replicate his wraith or do
we want new
villains I'd love to see what you guys
think in the comments for that I'd like
to see the go come back and have adapted
to the the new political climate of the
of the Galaxy because they're it's in
their nature to be to to want Power they
may have been defeated once but it's not
that's not going to stop them the system
Lords are gone but someone else will
just rise to power I'd like to see that
rise to power that I mean because since
they're parasitic in nature you know I
don't think they're really particularly
hung up on I mean they could be some
other thing you know it's just yeah
that's a great idea I love that yeah I'd
love to see necessarily have to be we're
going to be your Gods though it could be
anything they just want Power they just
want to be in in control of things they
want an Empire guys I hope the guy's
watching that has been arguing with me
for weeks and really really arguing
having a right go at me because he keeps
saying that the go W are extinct they're
all dead I say no just the system Lords
no when are you going to admit you're
wrong I'm
not I'm not wrong I want to see take the
furlings I think that would be awesome
yeah I'd love to see the furlings I I I
I genuinely think the fings as a villain
is a brilliant idea um but not like a
villain I think it's got to be like a
Thanos type of villain where they're not
they're not being evil for Evil's sake
they're actually doing it for like a
good reason but that good reason [__]
us up or something um a fos type of
villain would be yeah they they think
they think they're doing the right thing
yeah yeah but then not but well they're
not for us at least
um okay Arnold G's got a good thing
which just would it be funny to make a
spoof SG traveled to a planet where the
Lord of the Rings is happening man talk
about you know throwing another ring
into the mix for rings of power you made
a knack with a
man I like um there's a meme where it's
Doctor Who he jumps out he comes through
the Stargate he's like ah
something I like that um eily walks
chilling go
psycho um I wouldn't mind seeing the
ghoul take over the unises again kind of
go back to their roots in a way because
they took the unises over before
people yeah yeah because the unus are
kind of getting
smarter yeah Ken's late but he's got a
note from his mom so it's okay um yeah I
I like the idea of seeing the go W
trying to come I I had this idea
actually that the gold W are actually
behind the Lucian
Alliance and um and that explains how
the Lucian Alliance sort of got control
of all that technology so quickly and
and why they how they expanded so
quickly and um I actually think that
would be a good idea bring the ghou back
that way because they've been behind the
Lucian Alliance the whole time sort of
thing uh secretly the Lesser gold not
the system
Lord
dead
but
and
I yeah yeah they've just adapted to the
new situation sort of thing they they
used God like things people before they
can't do that anymore so they use
Commerce
and trick them people and maybe and and
people wouldn't even need to know yeah
the alliance wouldn't even
know
so I think that would work a gou crime
syndicate they're the now the Godfathers
of the good fellow of the the Stargate
world yeah yeah exactly um because it
didn't it never really made sense to me
that Lucian L got so powerful so quickly
yeah how do they use the technology how
did they you know because the gold were
very clever to like make sure that
nobody knew how to you know use their
technology and keep people down so uh I
like that idea anyway that was me but um
so so how did we sorry how did we answer
that question do we want new villains do
we want want to see the old ones come
back or do we want to mix all the above
yeah I want all yeah yeah yeah or just
have spin-offs you know the the the gold
you know Stargate you know the uh gold
you know
Stargate theuts you know just just just
just just go spin out spin off crazy
just nutso with it you
know yeah yeah yeah I like that idea
what you what you think Matt mix new
villain go old school bring ra back I
want to see come back just because I
don't think they they they would give up
that
[Music]
easily I don't know I'd like to see some
new
villains because having the same
villains over and over again would get a
little bit boring but I think you could
do so much more with the gold than they
did yeah B was the closest I think to do
to going that extra mile because he
actually infiltrated Earth and became
like a businessman on Earth and I
thought that was brilliant like doing
things like that
yeah like infiltration and like taking
over from the inside and
just being dicks like just being being
being actual like businessmen in in in
in the world how they are and you could
be like it's because you're a gold Elon
Musk you're a
gold yeah I it' be clever I like that
yeah yeah and and we would again it
would be stripping Stargate back a
little bit I do think when you've after
after a 15year
gap they've I I think going back to the
beginning a little bit is not a bad idea
you know going back not to what JJ
Abrams wanted to do and actually go back
to Raw that was a stupid idea um but um
going back to the beginning a little bit
is not a terrible idea you know and
going back to the goal world at least to
begin with is not a bad idea they sort
of go with home a little bit isn't it
let's go they'll start with something we
know what would you like it if they
played it like the ghou where like the
the lowly kind of underlying villains
the secondary villains for like the
longevity of the series and then maybe
they kind of have like a puppeteering
moment by the end and we do realize that
oh yeah they're not just in control of
like the Lucian Alliance but they're in
control of this group this group this
group or this group and then they're
kind of like that large large large
threat again I don't know well like
there there was one episode where um I
forget which uh series it was in uh they
encountered some sort of uh spaceship
that was just armed to the teeth but
they never really explained who was in
it what if that was just another go old
infected society that we could pick up
on and you know what I mean does that
make any sense yeah I forget what
episode that was that was was that SGU
in the alternate universe
though could be they were G use more of
that could be yeah yeah yeah so one
thing that um I was wanting to say there
was a race of aliens in Star Atlantis in
in
Deus variations I think the episode was
called when they kept going through
different realities is it that yes yes
yes yes the encyclopedia is correct that
was it yes you got a it a brilliant
episode it was a brilliant
episode yeah yeah you never hear from
them again yeah bring him back to go all
old you know God loved me some you know
apus but I was watching the expans this
last week and I said who is that guy who
is that dude and it was the theme actor
that was playing in an episode of
expanse was also he was the he played a
office Peter Williams I
think yeah Pete Williams is a great
actor the episode where he died the last
time he died is properly good acting
it's oh he also died in this too so he
dies a lot yeah well that's how to
that's how to do your job right
um f yeah that's not a good point don't
need to reinvent the wheel um I mean we
keep hearing rumors that it's is going
to be an
sg1 reboot remake whatever you want to
call it and but in that they'll use that
formula and that's what we want to see
isn't it or or do we want to see
something that again is a little bit
different more like SGU or sgaa or in
the wider universe or would that just be
stupid I'd like to
see Matt go on youo first because I
don't know what either of you said then
that way no okay I'd like to see them
elsewhere um not just on
Earth but not necessarily as far as
starget Universe maybe a different
galaxy
like like they inhabited Pegasus but not
necessarily like 30 40 galaxies way
where they can't get home I like I like
being a to get
home okay
stormy yeah I I I think I'd like to you
know definitely uh see something new you
know
um just let the writers run with it and
see what they come up with you know like
um you know strange new Rings you know
we're following the uh the uh disne dis
model
strange the paramite model just strange
new Rings or U Stargate Discovery I
think that would be another good
direction we could go
in how old infected Vulcans I love that
idea weird
Klingons
weird oh just oh man just plasticine
they look all they look like morph from
when we were kids uh about you Harrison
what what what do you want to see is it
an sg1 does it do we go home or do we do
something new I I I mean I
like doing something new but technically
staying at home in the same time we have
two galaxies in in Pegasus and milky
white to explore so why don't we do that
we technically have a third Galaxy
what's the Galaxy that the orai are from
we could we could totally go in there
and help out the Galaxy as
well the original home of the Ancients
yeah original original home I don't
think it was ever given a name probably
just called origin they probably named
it origin we have a couple we could
totally work
with I mean Fleet Admiral's got a point
there that I mean when the series comes
back
initially there's got to be a villain
obviously in the first series because
what would be the point otherwise but
actually there is a lot for them to tell
yeah there's you know there's there's a
lot of story there to to explain and I
think one of the story arcs for me I
think they should do flashbacks through
the series that you know do the um
disclosure so we tell the disclosure
project but instead of doing it in one
hit I think they should do it in Little
Bits through the series or something um
so we don't really know what's quite you
know because they can ask questions then
can't they and then answer them a couple
of episodes later and keep us wondering
sort of thing but um how would you how
would you guys handle the this has
become a Stargate video again how did we
manage that oh
having a
chat
um how how would you guys do the
disclosure how would you manage it as I
say I would do it through flashbacks but
how would you guys do it Harris how how
would you do it mate I love flashbacks
but I if it's a longer series I worry
about that because arrows just the thing
that comes to mind like those those like
first maybe two seasons of flashback for
great and then you just it just got into
like oh great now half an episode's
flashback sometimes
uh if it was a miniseries flashbacks are
perfect uh with that I I just I just
think people's actions uh
maybe I'd say use dialogue and
Exposition but like have that done not
just for the sake of it have like
someone react a certain way and then
prompt a question from an from a
character maybe someone's doing
something really stupidly and they're
doing it because they're like headstrong
about something because this happened
here and so on and so forth uh I think
there's some natural ways to do
it all
dream um how about how about you stormmy
how would you do it you know I I was
just thinking about that and I and I I
was visualizing you know like
um some SG members they're around a
campfire you know you see the gate in
the background you know and they're just
you know talking you know talking shop
you know one's cleaning his gun and
everything God it's so peaceful here I
know right it's just certainly isn't
Earth then you cut to Earth and
everything's just on fire everyone's mad
and everyone and they finally disclose
the Stargate program which has been
going on now for 30 years and so it's
just I think that' be a great opener you
just see these two Stargate guys that
some you know SG4 SG4 whatever they're
just casually talking you know soaking
up the vibe of some dist I don't know
they're Andromeda this time and they say
yeah sure as hell isn't Earth and then
you flash back to Earth and all
everything's just tops eternity and then
and because that you know because then
you see how all of a sudden we Earth
became one of these crazy ass planets
that's got all this [__] going on that
sg1 was traveling through and you know
seeing all their turmoil now all of a
sudden that's us and then kind of play
it from that Ang I don't know what do
you think here
I I like that idea I really like that
idea I think I think I'd do something
similar okay Matt do you think there has
to be
disclosure I think it's been too long
and they already had so many close calls
when they were on the air for them not
to have [__] something up to make it
so they had to
disclose I think they would have done
something I mean the a
uh plague I thought was going to be the
Catalyst for them um disclosing the um
the Stargate project to begin
with but there's got to be there's got
to be so many other
things we said it in previous videos
they've got na generators that they
don't they don't let people on Earth use
they must have given those at least like
morally you'd have to think they'd have
to have given them to people in like
third world countries and stuff to try
and get their their cultures
like just improve their way of lives
even if it it's not like third world
countries if it's just in America or
just in
Canada they're going to question where
this technology came from and eventually
it's going to get to the point where
they're gonna have to just disclose but
yeah as I say I think the the Ori plague
would have been the Catalyst and I was
surprised it didn't happen then so I'd
be very surprised if it hasn't
happened maybe it has happen and we just
call it
co as soon as Co happened as soon as it
happened I was like it come from the all
right
galaxy stormy though do we have to have
disclosure
though I think at some point in time you
know it it it becomes like the elephant
in the room like you know Matt was
saying there's so many events you know
and so many questionable things you know
they they should start off with um you
know somebody on YouTube with a channel
that's going through well you know
is and then there'll be some
whistleblower like bobar talking about
you know the Stargate program and no
one's listening to him and then
there's at some point in time you're
going to have to have disclosure because
something that
big is I mean you know Bob lazar's thing
was well you know yes we had we're we're
in a possession of alien craft well the
whole Stargate Universe is oh yeah yeah
yeah alien craft yeah sure we got that
but we've been we've already travel to
three galaxies not including whatever
has happened with uh Universe the
destiny so yeah at some point in time
it's just go but the longer they go the
more um I think the more disruptive
it'll be to Earth in culture well Harris
I mean you for one do you think it has
to happen but would you if you were
doing it would you have disclosure as
part of the new season would you do
would you build that into your storyline
for the first season that that's
happening or would you do would you
would you start the season after after
you know that it's already happened sort
of thing i' kind of try to find I don't
know just I try to find like a happy
middle medium somewhere uh where I mean
think think about it like us governments
had to release documents that like there
are things that we don't necessarily
understand what the hell they are out
there so maybe and no one really seems
to bad an eye so maybe like maybe the
Public's out there and like we have
released some stuff and no one's batting
an eye and no one really cares maybe we
have like a semi upgraded maybe we have
NAA generators on Earth maybe we have
some like upgraded military and stuff
like that so we're like a little more
like modern sci-fi kind of in the sense
like Avengers is all five years forward
now maybe we're like seven or 10 15
years ahead of where we thought we would
be right now and like it's kind of like
a an Open Secret in a way but there's
going to be like your Alex Jones type
there's going to be those people that
are going to be like this is going on
but nobody really believes it kind of
deal gay frogs you know he did that
story about gay frogs and it was
actually
true
insane this these pharms they were
dumping in the water supply makeing the
freaking
t or
maybe and the frogs would [__] anything
well it was turning all the it wasn't
turning the frogs gay necessarily but
what it was doing it was stopping them
from turning into women they were all
boys basically because of this
fertilizer I think it was um so the
story was actually true I'm watching
Alex Jones go gay Fox and T was taking
the mick out of him for it and it was
true but anyway um K I hope this
Stargate did a Five Nights at Freddy for
the fans unlike what Marvel did with the
Marvels which was a flop thoughts
um the Marvel seen either one of those
movies cu the Marvels is tfold the
better movie out of the two
and
oh FN AF was not for the fans either
it I like
the yeah I think the Marv but um I'm not
watching Five Nights at Freddy's Five
Nights at Freddy not watching so I'll
watch it when it comes when it's on I'm
oh it's it's already on peacock they
they literally released it the day on
peacock the day before aired because
they knew how bad the reviews were going
to be we don't get peacock here in
Britain ah so um I don't know what the
sort of NBC puts it on it'll be on
there'll be a sky Channel but it'll
it'll be on Sky Cinema very shortly and
I'll watch it on there but um but um
yeah
I the Marvels flopped because nobody
wants to watch I honestly think there's
a problem with Disney that people can't
be asked to go to the cinema to watch
Disney movies because they know it's
going to be on Disney Plus in a couple
of months and I do think there's that I
I have that in the back of my mind
whenever I think about it's 40 quid to
go I could just wait two months well
also the marveles technically isn't a
flop they if you look at what they've
made today they've only made 40 million
in the states so like domestic or
whatever but 100 million globally
already and that's in three days and
that is not what it was expected to make
they were thinking 40 to 60 million
total so it's I mean I'm I'm surprised
I'm standing up for the Marvels but like
like I mean
so it's a flop it's it's the lowest
performing Marvel movie so that yes very
much so yeah didn't Indiana Jones beat
that
number I'm not sure was
like um John's gonna go watch it in two
hours I think I assume that's the
Marvels you'll enjoy it it's good film I
enjoyed it I watch it last the musical
was funny but ify but not too
bad I think with the um Carri stop it it
you're going to get we're going to have
to tell you off again I'm going to have
to ban you from the channel if you carry
on but even though super chats are most
graciously appreciated and we will
always read them out uh sorry five
nights was bad I meant how they made it
for the fans and made more money than
expected they did make more they
did um so I mean you can't argue with
that um is a movie is a movie flop if it
makes a
profit
there's an element of making of reaching
expectation though isn't
there it's semantics in a way uh it just
depends how you're looking at it
yeah it did let's let's say let's not
call it a flop let's say it didn't meet
expectations we say that you know um
yeah but actually it's not a bad film if
you go out there and watch it give it a
go because it is actually quite a good
film I think it's
I would put this up against the Marvel
films from 10 years ago and say okay it
wouldn't be it's sort of like Thor the
first Thor movie not Ragnarok Ragnarok
is way better but the first Thor movie
it's good film it's not bad it's not as
good as Iron Man we'll put it that way
you know what I mean it's an in
between that sort of level yeah likee
was saying you know it's um I just I
mean these days I just wait till it come
out digitally then I either rent it or
buy it because that's a lot cheaper and
there's so it's not like I'm sitting at
home bored with nothing to watch with
all these damn channels you know there I
mean I I was totally watching all sorts
of stuff this week you know and uh did
not lack entertainment and so why go to
the theater when I can you know stretch
out on my nice comfy
sofa text all I want during the movie
hit pause and go use the bathroom or go
eat snacks or make you know dollar
popcorn just that it I I I think that
the the the movie house model is just
kind of suffering and there's not a
really good answer to it you know I mean
even big you know big movies that you
have to go see on the big screen like
Oppenheimer I just ordered it you know
I'm just waiting for it you know to to
download to my uh to my library and then
I'll just watch it from home oh that's
one you should have gotten seen in IMAX
if you had the chance yeah you know
Daddy has to work
but but yeah so I get that a whole lot
is just well do I watch this or you know
and now it's come out like do I go to
the theater or to watch the movie that
just came out that Friday that
downloaded to my library maybe I should
just stay home and watch that so now
I've got all these premieres coming to
my library so so do I watch that or do I
Flash Forward two months into the future
or and only you know and there's not a
lot of movie theaters that'll let me in
the Ador with just my underwear the only
there's only one I can think of and
that's Rocky har and they're not playing
locally that's not playing locally
unfortun yeah yeah L
say yeah and um and I can't you can't
pause at a de Cinema and go for a Wii
which as we know I have to do often yes
so the last film I thought I have to see
this at IMAX though was Dunkirk there's
not many films that come out that I go I
must see this at that was
amazing um that that was a phenomenal
movie um I just think the cinema is I
don't think Cinema's dying I think the
cinema didn't we just have one of the
best months in years or something yeah
oh yeah we had a a record couple months
yeah but um right it's unpredictable
yeah it's it's at the moment just about
every film that you've expected to do
well this year besides Barbie and
Oppenheimer I think those are literally
the only
exceptions Barbie was not exped well and
Barbie wasn't expected to do that well
either yeah it was expected um who was I
talking
to I was talking to somebody um I think
I'm allowed to say who it was when I
can't remember but anyway I was somebody
says that there there's a reason why
they spent um did they nearly double the
budget of the movie on advertising and
what have on the marketing there's a
reason why they spend normally you would
spend 30 or $40 million on marketing
they spent like hundred and something
stupid million dollars because they were
ex there was genuine thinking it's might
bomb so they just went let's go all in
and they just went all in and it worked
they changed the tube station name they
changed barban they changed it to Barbie
can yeah yeah just for the movie release
on Premier day oh my
God just all sorts of things like that
it's just you know they really really
did go all in and um and but the the the
the the risk worked you know um but they
they really thought it was going to bomb
and because they just you just don't
know what the bloody hell's going to
happen with Cinemas at the moment it's
just mental yeah who would have
genuinely thought you genuinely you'd
think with Indiana Jones movie you don't
need to Market that or in Mission
Impossible you don't need to Market them
they'll both do amazing Top Gun 2 did
incredible of course the next Tom Cruz
movie is going to do great and it was
shocking yeah um massive
flop
so something like top gun
Maverick yeah that would be a good idea
yeah why not why not so guys what we
what we've been watching this week then
before we before we call it a day we've
already gone past the hour so what we
been oh Harris Storm's
ready I'm up to season six of my uh
binge expanse that I started last week
um watched lessons in chemistry if you
haven't been watching that on Apple
[Music]
Plus pardon is it any good because the
wife wants to watch that
and instead Brie Larson is excellent in
it she it's just it's really good um I
got
I haven't seen the last episode that's
on my schedule for today and I got
caught up on the morning show not
exactly sci-fi but there is a rocket in
it so there is that I've just started
watching The Morning Show I quite like
it I'm on the third episode or so and
Matthew I know exactly while you just
went off for a minute for a few seconds
so don't pretend if you're going to
disappear off to vape and then try and
hide it don't then come back with the
Vape still in your hand so we can see it
I wasn't doing it to hide I just know if
I do on stream someone's gonna complain
so well yeah
it's don't eat on stream either so uh
oppenheim did so well AKA nasty yeah um
I've watched Oppenheimer my God it's
boring it's an important story but darly
Lord is boring um I may have fallen
asleep at one point and I watched it
during the day it was like 2 o'clock in
the afternoon or something but I'm
getting that age now where I've started
fall asleep halfway through the day I
was at work last week and I goes I was
woken up by somebody phoning me I was
like oh yeah that's right yeah yeah yeah
uh Laura Smith morning excuse me uh Co
said yeah all mankind is back it's also
my to watch
L yes I heard my partner is telling me
it is
excellent EXC Beacon 23 is the thing
that's on MGM I think isn't it is that
right is that the new show that's on MGM
plus Beacon
23 I don't know that sounds semi SciFi
big Sci-Fi show it does look really
really good I didn't know it was out I
thought it was out next week but yeah it
looks really interesting h no it's not
is it um it is MGM plus yeah it is on
MGM plus that's the shows on about then
uh who's the star in it because it's
quite a big star in it isn't it Lena Hy
from Cersei from Game of
Thrones yeah yeah yeah yeah the one from
Sarah Conor Chronicles yes I love her
very
much yeah Mike just wait you just wait
Mike yeah you just
wait what Mike just G sto me off
[Music]
then it's so inappropriate to you
people so
inappropriate
um and I've seen the certain comments by
the way that we're not mentioning in a
video ever ever again but I've seen the
comments you're very naughty
people Harris what you been watching my
friend uh I think we talked about a
little bit yesterday but Loki Marvels um
so the finale for Loki Marvels the last
three episodes so the finale for the
first season of scavengers Reign I don't
know when it's coming to the UK but the
second it is you'll have to watch it and
if you're in the US watch scavengers
reain if you're in anywhere in the world
that you can watch scavengers rain watch
scavengers rain because it's it's the
best show that's been on TV for the past
month two months about tell us about it
briefly it's uh a a freighter ship in
space gets kind
of something happens and a solar flare
hits the freighter and causes uh them a
few people in the freighter because not
everyone's awake a lot of people are in
stasis so the ones that are awake have
to escape to a planet and some Escape
pods don't make it this is all in the
like literal intro of the show every
episode uh and you are following three
different storylines of different
survivors that are on the planet and
it's very strip back there's not a whole
bunch of talking at at first you get a
little more talking by the last kind of
six episodes but it is fantastic it's
it's it's these people having to explore
a new world and are trying to get back
to the demer which is their ship and try
to find a way to get off the planet
it's good simple but fun super sci-fi
super
sci-fi uh say what is it high concept
sort of thing or no no uh High Concept
in uh the way the planet Works in some
ways it's not like high Concept in like
a flashy like cities built everywhere
it's super I mean it's it's in the
wilderness kind of thing they're they're
hiking in the wilderness to get to their
spaceship so it's it's only High Concept
in like the way the planet interacts
with them and the way they interact with
the planet but it's cool it's so cool
scavengers rain um he got the weat yes
sir he had to do a Jamie that's what
we're gonna be starting calling don't
know
when coming soon to a store near
you uh besides that though special ops
lioness I'm still on my Taylor shared in
Paramount plus run special fly was
really good very good and then
newepisode the day of Rick and Morty uh
kopoulos the fantasy version of it
essentially and uh lamman bass Reeves
more more Taylor Sheridan so I'm
happy I know I've said this before but I
actually think quietly power Mount plus
has become my favorite streaming service
but the app is [__] the app is so
annoying so we start day it crashes oh
I've start to watch Stone right so you
know normally you'll go into show and
obviously the fifth season's just come
out so you go into it and it's the fifth
season but you go down to Seasons and
you just go back you can't do that with
Yellowstone on [__] Paramount roll
all the way search Yellowstone and find
the first
season it's so
annoying the only saving grace is my
Amazon app remembers which episode I
watched last and it's on my continue
watching that's the only saving Grace
but you actually go into the Paramount
app you can't do it it's I mean so
stupid it's really annoying but I
actually think on the quiet Paramount is
becoming one of my I I watch it way more
than I watch it might be because I found
it recently I've not so so I'm going
back through but Yellowstone is
fantastic I'm GNA look forward to
watching the prequel lionesses was
fantastic um a really beautiful made
show I only watch Paramount and Apple at
the moment I watch Netflix pound for
pound I genuinely can't remember the
last time I watched Netflix and if
you've got apple plus and if you haven't
you need to watch slow horses it's a
brilliant show it's
hilar who's that sounds for who's that
who's got who's in that it's I can never
remember his
name it's a British it's a show B in
Britain with spies and it's a spy show
um but the the basic
principle is that in MI5 they've got
these um uh basically oh Gary alman's
the main star Gary I've seen I've seen
ads for
that um it's basically the rejects from
MI5 and Gary Oldman is like the the boss
but he hates everybody he's always
telling them how stupid they are and
stuff and he's just I wouldn't trust him
to tell me the time if he was stood in
front of Big Ben was one of my favorite
lines um and go and then like should
they're like there's this guy that's
been kidnapped and they goes should we
go and save him I goes no for the love
of God don't do that that's a shire way
that he'll definitely get killed if you
go try and save him so just go and do
nothing that way we've got half a chance
sort of thing so he's just absolutely no
but then actually when one of them gets
hurt he like I know he's an idiot but
he's my idiot so he's like he's really
loyal to him but um it's a brilliant
show it's really really good very funny
very clever um and quite dark in place
as well um and you know twists and turns
but it's oh it's fantastic Gary Alman
one of the great generation add that to
my never growing list ending just
Invasion on Apple guys I've tried this
show and I'm really struggling with it
get has anybody watched it does it get
better I it it
it's I I I really like the first season
but as it's just dragged on you know you
got the chick talking to the blob and
the blob doing [__] and it's just I I
kind I just it is it is it takes a lot
of personal energy for me to watch an
episode is
that H is that Josh brolan
one no Josh no I don't think he is in it
is he but I know there is a show with
Josh Bolin in isn't there I really like
him um no it started off with um the guy
from
um piss yeah it yeah Jurassic
Park Jurassic Park started off with the
guy from Jurassic Park died almost
instantly so I was like oh hope they
didn't pay him too much um but um I'm
I'm struggling with it I'm just
like when this is going to get to a
point when something you know it's like
I think I've watched three episodes and
I'm really struggling to to care enough
to um Sam Neil thank you sir
um Brad W always recoil from sharing
story details of UND developed Stargate
series I I think and good name by the
way thank you for that I wish I'd read
your name before about the
comment um I think it's partly because
he doesn't actually own a lot of the
story because anything that is
um it's paid for by mg
but I do wonder if it's more to do the
point that he's saving it I I think he's
quite a clever man Brad wri and I think
at some point if he writes a book about
the stories that never got made in his
Memoirs or whatever we will go freaking
crazy but if he drops that in YouTube
videos It's s have given it away for
free in it yeah so I I think there might
be an element of that so he does stop
himself so he he'll start and then go oh
I've said too much we're all there going
say more
don't shut up I I think that's that's
where it was it WR by Steve Simon
kingberg was it um Invasion I like Simon
King I hope he gets to make movie even
though I'm 95% certain He's Not Gon but
um you have a look at Simon kingberg
IMDb in production like 30 something
things in
production he co-wrote all of Star Wars
Rebels with Dave Fon which I think he's
one of the reasons it's so damn good and
he should have came back for
Ahsoka yeah yeah okay how about you um
Matty have you watching anything good
this week what are you watching at the
moment not really I watched Loki season
two uh yeah season two watched the last
two episodes of that yesterday I watched
a bit of The Walking
Dead uh it's pretty much it really done
much yeah I can't watch them I got so
bored do I need to give another do I
need to give that another try as
well um where are you at I would say the
first four seasons really good five epes
and and then what am I on now season
nine yeah season Seven's pretty good and
season eight but season nine so far is
pretty
boring and it might be because Rick has
gone I don't know
but I'll do it I like the D dud with the
baseball Pat and The Nine Inch Nails
through it but I like the that that yeah
Jeffrey D Morgan yeah like literally his
his Arc is like the best and he's still
in it he's still in it but I just
haven't seen him for like five episodes
I think he's still in in a jail cell or
something he was the best thing know his
character in Watchman even though he's
barely in it but oh he's so good
comedian yeah yeah
you said minut ago looking for to dead
City that's the that's there with Maggie
and Negan I'm looking forward to that
just because of
Negan
yeah I need a show to watch when I'm at
work I'm pretending to work I need
something in the background when I'm
pretending to work so maybe I'll go with
that it's always sunny oh and I've been
watching Star Trek
obviously oh yeah you're on TNG aren't
you of course you are man good man yeah
Seas I think damn it I put his name up
again third or fourth oh well never mind
it was a good comment so scrip um sorry
Harris sty were you gonna say something
man I think I interrup oh oh uh Netflix
I started watching the first two
episodes of this anime called blueeye
Samurai each episode's about an hour
long and it is amazing it is really
really good uh it's about a a a s
samurai or someone that was like an
orphan that was raised by a sword maker
that kind of trained to be a samurai in
their spare time kind of deal but
they're uh they have blue eyes so
they're like a half half breed
essentially in like Colonial like Japan
before they like shut their borders off
there's not L there's not any white
people in Japan left anymore so uh she
she's kind of considered a demon kind of
deal and they're like oh this is and you
know it's just a really cool little
story but it's it's really good so far
uh but just just a whole different topic
you made me think of it earlier while we
were talking about Paramount did you see
that uh Warner Brothers was talking
about that they just literally gave
Paramount as an example of a company
that they want to buy they're looking to
invest and buy a big company that so War
Brothers is considering buying
Paramount good
Lord
truth the the rumor I heard last week um
was that again yeah Warner Brothers
would be very interested in because one
of the main reasons is Paramount
basically is the other that has sort of
the biggest studio in California other
than Warner Brothers they have the
biggest Backlot so they basically one
way of doing is they would basically
monopolize Studio space in in
California also obviously there's the
back catalog of things but the problem
is Warner Brothers can't afford to buy
Paramount um so the one question was
there was GNA be sort of like a joint
deal with Netflix that Netflix buy
Paramount
plus and have first dibs on a lot of the
rights and then they will pay for that
and basically then Warner Brothers were
looking at buying just the studio of
Paramount and NBC would absorb a big
chunk of the rest there's also a rumor
that paraman getting ready to do to sell
and one of the things they're getting
ready to do is actually buy Alex
curtzman out of secret
hideout and Rebrand secret hideout as
Star Trek
Studios um so that basically they can
bring Star Trek back into the fold
because the problem is secret hideout
owns certain elements of the Star Trek
franchise now they own what they've
produced basically so Paramount couldn't
say say if you cancel contract for
secret hideout tomorrow Paramount
couldn't continue to make strange new
worlds because even though they own Star
Trek they don't own elements of strange
New World secret hideout does um under
the deal it's not really own it but it's
like the sort of copyrighy thing it's a
bit complicated the guy that did explain
it to me honest P the George
Lucas sorry they pull a George Lucas
yeah yeah so that's the that's the
that's the idea yeah that um Netflix
would basically buy and absorb Paramount
plus and they would um basically do a
deal with Warner Brothers so Netflix
would basically take over Max and take
over Paramount plus and it would become
one it would all come under Netflix
because H Max is doing quite
badly on the streaming platform in
America you have to explain explains to
me there's a streaming platform and then
is there is it like a network thing as
well because there's like HBO's still
there
cable network they still have HBO on
like cable network stuff but Max is no
longer HBO Max but it's it's still what
it was so the streaming would shift to
Netflix Power Plus would shift to
Netflix and um but Warner Brothers would
take over the studio so Warner Brothers
would continue to produce material for
Netflix but Netflix would own the thing
and that's apparently the only way
Warner Brothers can Finance it and
that's what they're looking at at the
moment
but this isn't going to happen anytime
soon because it's going to be a
massively complicated deal and Warner
Brothers are going to have to massively
refinance to do it because they owe 50
60 billion dollars already oh do you
think that'll like because if they're
that's almost a a hub of different apps
like we were talking about with Amazon
earlier does that kind of coers Amazon
into trying to toss an offer at
Paramount would that maybe make apple
say hey maybe we want to toss an offer
instead of their Disney talks maybe I
don't know if apple and Paramount teamed
up that'd be kind of Glorious in my
opinion but yeah I mean i' I'd love to
see something like that but we're gonna
have to have it I I think Apple will
always survive because financially they
can they could lose money in trillions
no um I mean they got hundreds of
billions in checking I mean yeah they're
fine but they can always sort of be that
quality over quantity they're almost
like a specialist yeah screaming service
the rest of them aren't so I I do think
I was talking to a business analyst
about this um I God last year now and he
was saying that that that there is going
to be a correction there's too many of
these apps now and all these little
companies are doing stream like Lion
gate over in the UK have got their own
streaming app and they're like they're
taking the piss it's just it's just
getting silly they can't all have their
own streaming app it's got It's going to
there will be a collapse um and he he
actually said the first major one to go
will be Paramount Plus not worked it's
it hasn't worked it's cost an absolute
Fortune um Paramount I mean they banked
a lot on Mission Impossible this year
Mission Impossible didn't make what it
wanted to do and they they have a few
different things that it just the things
that they were banking on didn't bank so
it's not looking good Mission Impossible
is another one of those things I just
got off the uh bu with my library I
didn't get to the movies to see it's
still damn good though it's so good it
was I thought it was holy [__] this is
good now I'm just so pared up I want to
see part two well they just changed it
it's no longer part two thankfully
that's they changed it to it's no longer
part two so now the next one's just
gonna be Mission Impossible eight I
think yeah which is smart back his name
no they
haven't so they have not bought Curts
out of his contract yet but that is the
conversation that's happening um he is
going to do magnificent 7 MGM though but
Alex curtzman
is doing that is Alex kurtzman not
secret hideout so secret hideout and not
producing so um but Alex kurtzman has
done several projects over the last even
the few years the secret hideouts deal
is basically to do Star Trek and then
get first dibs and anything secret
hideout does but Alex curtzman can still
work as a producer on other projects so
it's not happened yet but I would put I
wouldn't give you good odds on that
it'll happen in the next six months he
just said happen on Friday and a
followup I don't know if that's just
like super recent or not you want sorry
he I don't want to say his name but he
just said happened on Friday I don't
know if that just
like I missed it if it did so I mean
that is excellent if that happened
Friday I'll I'll I'll look into it but
um I I knew I know I knew it was planned
but if it happened great but I know he's
doing Magnificent Seven but that's
separate secret hideout since when is
that a thing that that just piqued my
interest as you started saying that when
when do we get that is that being made
yeah yeah
apparently yeah MGM y so but he's got if
you look at his IMDb he's got several
projects that nothing to do secret
hideout on the go that he's producing so
for other other providers um when they
do Star Trek 4 which I think will happen
at some point that will be Alex kurtzman
with secret that will be secret hideout
producing it um I I think kurtzman has
been moving away from secret hideout for
a while to be honest he's um and
Paramount considered a lot of the toxic
toxicity with Star Trek in the last 12
months last sorry the last few years is
aimed at Alex kursman even with peard
doing well people still [__] about Alex
kursman so um kurtzman you know it's
like what he did with Discovery season
one has left a bad taste in people's
mouths you know it's like it's it was
not good it was a bad way it was a bad
step it was a very bad First Step yeah
and getting him out of it and um and
like I say I this idea of re rebranding
as Star Trek Studios sort of what
they've it's almost like Lucas within
Disney and sort of things that it'll be
within the thing but separate slightly
and um I I actually think that was a a
really really good idea if they do that
I like it because that that allows them
if they do want to leave that company at
any point or if another company wants to
buy out Star Trek particularly if
they're just not working within those
confines whatever they end up doing that
can be done at that point they can go in
there and grab Star Trek without having
all those strangle holds from different
places yeah yeah that's just I think
healthy for an IP yeah exactly and
simplifying all the the contracts have
got so confusing with Star Trek over the
last few years when CBS and Paramount
separated and then CBS owned the movie
rights sorry Paramount owned the movie
rights cbso and the TV rights and then
that got convoluted when they then
reabsorbed because all these contracts
still sort of stood and it complicated
so it's it's become really complicated
then they allowed secret Hout to take on
certain elements of the IP and it's just
uh just so absorbing it in is the cheap
but the end of the day what pount are
thinking is even if it costs them x
amount of millions to buy Paramount to
buy out secret
hideout it absorbs Secret hide out into
Paramount and Star Trek will be more
valuable because of it at the
moment it's it's it's probably their
most valuable IP and they don't own all
of it and that's a problem if you're
then going to try and sell the
studio so if this happens if you see
secret hideout or if it did happen
Friday and I just missed it sorry um if
this does happen the next few months
expect Paramount to be sold before the
summer because that's I'm told that's
when they have to restructure load of
their
debt and that's a problem for them
because it's going to cost a
fortune so they've got about 10 billion
worth of debt that they have to
restructure but they took that debt out
when um they were getting interest rates
of like 1% and now all of a sudden it's
5% and 5% of 10 billion dollar
is a
lot hundred million or something in
interest alone or something it's it's
going to be a problem so I I think
they're they're looking to sell
because of that makes
sense but we'll see or they'll
restructure and they'll just
keep that unification makes sense so
then it is like a ENT pole like a Marvel
would be under a Disney or or or Warner
Brothers under or or DC under like a
Warner Brothers thing or something like
that yeah yeah so yeah but I like the
Star Trek Studios idea I think that's a
good
idea and that was um one of actually my
comments fell I won't say his name but
he he told me about that and I was like
really and then I immediately asked
somebody else and they went who told you
that that's supposed to be a secret like
okay I found out again I tell you what
you know with the Star Trek being um
Stargate sorry and the um it being
released to the public let's just get us
to do it we've released everything else
we've ' you know we've leaked everything
else just leaked that the Stargate
exists as
well they could so do that you know like
how sometimes they do movies and things
when they use real news reporters and
stuff in the you know disaster movies
they could do the start of the movie
it's a YouTube video but
it's releasing the information sort of
the Stargate
real yeah that's hire us please let us
do it YouTube a leak
Secrets
again oh my God like uh that's what uh J
Jonah jeson was doing in the the Marvel
uh Spider-Man movies right he was kind
of working as like The Daily Bugle was
like a YouTube Network or something and
that's kind of what he was doing let's
do
it don't you know if they don't do it
then I don't know what's going
on um anyway guys it's been marvelous as
always I think I'm gonna go and have a
bath don't feel very well oh I'm so
sorry pee before you get in there just
to just to make sure
pee in there not in there but you know
you know what I mean I'll pee in the
shower I don't pee in the bath that's
wrong good good good there you go that's
the final question of the day pee in the
shower yes or no oh why not depends on
the
[Music]
day there were some days no but some
days yes hey I just want to tell you
guys we got a couple new videos up on my
professor cringe Channel I've got an
episode of
Dracula Dracula's uh up and I've also
got anep the first episode of foundation
is up on uh Professor cringe I'll put
the links to them in the chat I was
really happy how they turned out I
really you know I really enjoyed making
them you know it was like you guys said
like you advis you do something that
you're really passionate about have fun
with I really had a good time putting
these together so good go watch
them that's all see what have you just
sent
me you've not been listening you've been
doing
stuff
what CT will go by the end of November I
edited that video whil also listening to
this because I'm just that
skilled right um the the source that's
been talking to me about Star Trek he
says since he brought it up they have
brought kurts out of his contract he's
going to do magnificent 7 Fromm GM
they're trying to consolidate the IP
which I've been told rarely and they're
desperately trying to sell um yeah his
sources are a bit hit and missed so
because he's also person they' sacked
curtzman months ago and they turned out
not to be true so sometimes
unfortunately there's um I I think his
sources are genuine over NBC but they're
very much in the we hate Alex kurtzman
Camp and there is I I've spoken to a lot
of people over at Paramount and there
are Executives over at par that hate
Alex kurtzman and there are others that
don't so I mean it's um there's two
camps going on but
anyway let's call it a day gentlemen um
thank you so so much as always it's been
emotional um we've had really good
numbers in guys so thank you so much
again for supporting the channel um the
whole whole video when we didn't have a
topic sort thing we just wanted to hang
out and chill so it's really great that
um that that that you know you've you've
turned up we really appreciate it but um
yeah say say goodbye everybody goodbye
everybody
toles love you guys
[Music]
bye